my name is Brian Terry I'm an Oakland
based chef cookbook author and food
justice activist I am here today to
connect with Caleb and mu and talk about
health food agriculture issues and to
make a Slamon recipe from my book afro
vegan we're gonna do an all green spring
slide this be considered like an afro
vegan dish this was kind of squarely
inspired by growing up in the south but
living in Northern California wearing
like the hub of the kind of like good
food movement you a mistake you to eat
chicken eat turkey fish me to go out and
order a sounds kind of like foreign 3
I'm like that's not my thing I don't
necessarily think that that is the
perfect diet for everyone I think we
need to have a very nuanced complex
approach to diet we all have different
you know geographic regions from which
we come different bodily constitutions
you know our age all these things I
think we need to really consider when
thinking about what the best diet for us
is and so my goal is really getting
people eating real food again because I
think one of the biggest culprits
particularly Hmong community of color
its industrial food you know one of the
big steps is changing people's habits
and attitudes and politics around food
you know so many people in communities
that have lack of access to healthy
affordable food there's a culture of
eating bad because it just hadn't been
any healthy food there they had many
fresh foods there for decades so I think
it's about like starting just with these
kind of basic individual changes that
move into community-wide changes and
then eventually to make the policy
changes that we need to
make to really plan for my food system
there's something affordable to count
like get these ingredients and make it
happen sometimes the cost might be a
little more ninety cents on the dollar
goes to the actual person growing the
food whereas when you go to the big
corporate on a supermarket so much of
the money you spend is going towards
packaging and processing and marketing
and shipping so we need to think about
not just food justice but economic
security how can we you know actually
support the people who live among us who
we support our neighbors our friends and
ensure that people have jobs people have
money in their pockets to take care of
their family so it's a lot of arguments
to be made for spending money at these
local sources I'm gonna go home and I'm
gonna have jerk chicken but I might have
to move the rice out but then maybe I'd
incorporate a vegan salad into as well I
live and breathe this and but I know
that I can always push myself to be more
conscious about what I'm eating more
mindful this is a very tasty and you had
tofu in there and I'm not doing that big
fan of tofu office it doesn't taste like
anything once you put some spices on it
I think the beginner think of nuts like
people who are really crazy but I do
understand that they really are they're
being healthy and they and I can never
ever knock nothing like me I mean as you
get older you less and less than you one
is you know clogged arteries or whatever
my V my mom I've been trying to slowly
get her to be raw on a more plant-based
diet of just because I know she's
getting older she had hypertension
cancer with other thing that runs in her
family and I definitely heard to you
know be there when that day comes
there's this growing body of research
yes that is showing that you know plant
centered vegetable forward diets are
actually really helpful and for in terms
of preventing chronic illnesses and I
want to have like plant center you know
vegetarian and vegan food as a tool for
addressing this public health crisis
that we're seeing
you